you try to be a good employee you show
up you sit at your desk move things
around on it you update your screensaver
finally find the nearest printer
sometimes it's still all just too much
so here's a tip leave early leavin early
while it sounds challenging it's
actually really easy and great for your
mental health here's the first thing you
do create an event in your calendar for
the last half hour of the day that
you're supposed to be there now I have
to invite some people I'm gonna go with
this list of interns who don't work here
anymore
I'm also going to invite an actual
employee Peter beets will get an email
about it and then email me saying he
didn't know there was a meeting and I'll
say sorry I love you and accidentally
now at the same time I'm gonna book a
conference room on the seventh floor
there are never any conference rooms on
the seventh floor available so that
means Dan Am who works in conference
room booking is gonna email me saying
that and I'm gonna say oh no problem I'm
gonna move my meeting back to my office
now I'm professional and considerate and
now I have two alibis so now when I hang
this sign on my office at the end of the
day no one can say I wasn't in a meeting
and that ladies and gentlemen is how you
have a healthy work-life balance now if
you'll excuse me I have a gym membership
to cancel
you